pas besoin d'activer
jouent ce jeu dont vous êtes en train de
resserrer nos rangs pour lui
presque ce matin ont débuté les
festivités du jubilé de platine de la
reine elizabeth 2 les britanniques fait
les 70 ans de règne de la monarque le
plus long de l'histoire du pays
les célébrations ont commencé avec la
traditionnelle parade militaire entre
buckingham palace et or the world parade
parmi les invités présents dans les
travées les invités présents il y aura
des ambassadeurs les attachés militaires
comme comme moi par exemple qui seront
présents à londres
le premier ministre
la question
souvent le cas le qinghai et vous voyez
c'est vrai que la voix de léon zitrone
peut être nous manque parce que c'était
lui lorsque nous étions enfants qui
commentait ces grands événements
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir m seront
chères ici beckingham ouvert laisse
quand même le raid était son jubilé elle
arrive à l'instant et nous la saison
enfin
les filons montchaude
gerber du vecchio c'est depuis elizabeth
corps ever fait partie de la vie de
plusieurs générations de britanniques et
représente le socle d'une monarchie
secoué par les standards où on sait que
la célèbre poupée dont on ne citera pas
la marque à la salle et le parvis barbie
voilà a fait justement la poupée pour le
jubilé de la reine c'est cette poupée la
wii alors elle a été sold out les
chouettes alors il a regardé elle est
très très belle elle a été vendue en
trois minutes il est plus une barbier la
reine est une passion on peut dire ça
comme ça stéphane litige le trompe et
une bonne vivante aussi elle celle aime
les plaisirs de la vie si on va
découvrir deux petites images assez
insolite regarder la reine qui boit de
la bière normalement photographie jamais
la reine en train de boire ni manger et
donc là c'est une exception n'étant qu'à
on est en 95 je crois qu'une deuxième
fois en 2012
avec cette image alors là c'est la reine
elizabeth en mode rock star je voulais
vous montrer ça ce qui est une artiste
qui a dit c'est pas du tout la haine
vous montrer une reine totalement lisse
on dirait qu'elle a 30 ans donc elle a
décidé de faire sa propre poupée de la
reine en dix ans elle est beaucoup plus
ressemblante les cheveux sont plus
ressemblants donc ça et c'est là est
totalement disponible
[Rires]
elizabeth 2 au balcon de buckingham
palace vêtue d'un ensemble bleu se
déplaçant à l'aide d'une canne la
souveraine est accompagnée du duc de
kent 86 ans l'un de ses cousins à 96 ans
la santé déclinante de la reine
l'empêchent de passer les troupes en
revue pourtant un incontournable du
jubilé elle a donc confié cet honneur à
son fils charles le prince de galles en
habit militaire et à cheval
[Musique]
une parade militaire à laquelle
participent plus de 1500 soldats
britanniques avec leurs chapeaux en poil
d'ours mais aussi des chevaux parfois
récalcitrants
on attend évidemment la famille royale
sur le balcon ça c'est le grand moment
il y aura pas le prince andrew et il est
très très déçus puisque lui il aime bien
quand il ya du monde au balcon il a été
évincé ce que vous savez c'est pas très
très bien comporté avec les femmes le
pauvre mais il n'a qu'à venir en france
comme ça il deviendra ministre de
l'intérieur pour le défilé aérien elle
sort à nouveau sur le balcon entouré
cette fois ci des membres actifs de la
famille royale la royal air force
célèbre les soixante dix ans de règne de
la souveraine tout près d'elle l'un de
ses arrière petits fils louis 4 ans
facétieux visiblement incommodé par le
bruit des avions absents mégane et harry
les sexes repéré par la presse
britannique assiste pourtant à la
cérémonie mais à l'écart discrètement
petite précision quand même parce que
l'humour d'accord mais d'arbanats et un
non-lieu à dans la sphère on va mettre
le prince andrew qui est dans la
procédure est une affaire qui a été
réglée par la justice merci beaucoup à
vous christine messieurs säntis aux
figurines oui c'est le brave activement
great food
[Musique]
faites le qualifie god save the queen le
premier de la matinée celui ci était à
capella il y en aura d'autres tout à
l'heure sans doute plus majestueux oui
parce que l'athlète ne bousculent